let's talk about why the war in ukraine
is causing a global food crisis
ukraine is one of the world's biggest
exporters of green essentials like wheat
and corn but right now around 20 million
tons of grain are stuck there
and that's causing serious problems in
parts of the world that depend on that
supply like the middle east and africa
food shortage is not just real but it's
pushing people to the brink of
starvation there is a real risk that
multiple famines will be declared in
2022
and 2023 could be even worse so why is
all that grain stuck how is it affecting
the rest of the world and what's being
done to try to solve the problem
[Music]
ukraine is a huge country with a lot of
really fertile farmland in normal times
it grows enough to feed 400 million
people a year that makes ukraine a major
player in global food markets for
example it's the fifth biggest exporter
of wheat in the world
more than sixty percent of lebanon's
wheat imports come from ukraine in
somalia it's almost fifty percent and in
tunisia it's more than thirty-six
ukraine used to export around 6 million
tons of grain every month almost all of
that got shipped out through its big
seaports which provided a direct route
to the middle east and africa but the
war has changed everything russia has
blockaded the ukrainian coastline it's
taken control of some of the ports and
it's bombed others while the ukrainians
have planted mines in the sea as a
defense
so those major ports in places like
odessa and goliath can't ship anything
in or out it's just too dangerous
and because nothing's moving there's a
huge pileup of grain which is causing
even more problems the storage silos are
full there's no space for this year's
harvest which is happening now and
farmers aren't getting paid
legit
we cannot sell we are not bringing money
back home and we don't have
cash to to produce next
season's crop so with ukraine's sea
routes off the table right now people
have been trying to find alternatives to
get the grain out
some of it's being rerouted to ports in
poland or romania taken by train or
truck
or through smaller ukrainian ports on
the danube river their new ports were
unprepared they were tiny they were
never supposed to ship that much of rain
out of the country and that's just one
issue there are other big practical
challenges like finding enough trucks
and drivers the high cost of fuel and
the fact that ukraine's railway tracks
are wider than in most of europe so they
have to unload and reload the trains at
the border it's really
the merit team shipping that is key i
mean it used to handle 90 percent of the
ukrainian commodity export and that
cannot be compensated by other means of
transport and we can see that in the
numbers ukraine's gone from exporting 6
million tons of grain every month to
just 200 000 in march and it managed to
export about 1 million last month
a bit better but still a drastic drop
compared to before
a drop that people around the world are
feeling to keep the porch closed
as the harvest season is now
coming in in ukraine in july and august
it means a declaration of war on global
food security so what's being done to
try to open those ports well short of
ending the war itself the main option
people are talking about is creating a
safe sea corridor to allow the grain out
possibly enforced by another country or
the u.n
turkey has been trying to get the
negotiations going but both russia and
ukraine would need to agree on the terms
and let's face it we're talking about
two countries at war so of course both
sides don't trust each other
[Music]
progressive
[Music]
[Music]
adding to the distress is the issue of
stolen grain ukraine accuses russia of
taking its grain from the areas it
occupies and then selling it to other
countries something that russia denies
turkey recently seized a russian ship
suspected of carrying stolen grain but
released it a few days later ukraine and
its western allies are putting pressure
on countries not to buy any ukrainian
grain that's shipped out by russia but
when supplies are short and prices are
sky high this leaves many countries with
very hard choices africans in the
assessment
it is a choice between expressing
solidarity with ukraine on one hand and
you know risking the almost
immunostarvation of their populations
and when it comes to that choice i think
africans are going to pursue a path that
is going to ensure they get the food
supplies food is a basic need and you
don't moralize when you're starving
there are so many ripple effects from
the war but it's hard to overstate just
how big the impact of this grain crisis
really is
it's not just about shortages it's also
about prices everywhere going up because
of the disruption to the global food
markets you've also got the rising price
of fertilizer and fuel and then there's
climate change
right now long droughts are affecting
food production in places like east
africa and south america this crisis is
not happening in a vacuum so the world
is already dealing with the ongoing
corvette 19 pandemic and that means that
i've had a massive economic fallout we
have a situation where governments are
tapped out incomes are depressed and so
we were already in a difficult situation
and russia's invasion of ukraine has
only made it all worse
in case you missed it check out our
recent episode all about the russian
president vladimir putin we've linked it
here
[Music]